I got introduced to mushrooms.
Oh by outkast,
Dj swiff and that was a beautiful experience.
I introduced my wife to him because of that.
Yeah,
I can definitely see that.
Yeah.
There's something to them.
Yeah,
for sure.
There is me and l dude,
me and now enjoy mushrooms while we make music.
Do you really?
Yeah.
Mushrooms,
wheat and whiskey and drink whiskey,
drink some Tequila or what do you call the others?
Tequila and mezcal is it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he,
he drinks mass cal.
I drink whiskey and shrooms and week.
They usually,
we had drunk ants in here from yesterday.
Apparently Richard Rawlings brought this cinnamon Tequila and some of it had
spilled on the table and the answered found this is the young pop up everywhere.
Brushing them along.
Yeah.
They were everywhere.
They were drunk.
They were just drinking Tequila and it was just old giant line of,
I'm like,
they found the fucking bar in the middle of space and got added.
Yeah,
they found it and when we got here it was covered with the ants,
shrunk aunts.
My wife made me hang out at a bar all night last night with her and her friend.
They got shit faced drunk,
threw up in an Uber.
He's running through the hallway in their underwear back at the hotel.
That sounds like good night.
Yeah.
Growing up in the Uber,
like how many times does that happen in those poor bastards?
Yeah,
not forever.
I tipped the got damn near $100.
I was like,
when,
I'm sorry,
I apologize.
How much puke?
A large amount,
not Jay,
but enough to be aggravated because she had a bag.
So you know,
you think that the bad catches but it wasn't plastic,
you know,
it's uh,
it,
it gave a little leak.
If it's hard to get that smell out,
that puke smell,
it's cost about 150 bucks to get it together.
Puke,
smell out.
Really that shit is in your body.
Like imagine if you could turn yourself inside out and smell
Pete's first far to the morning,
but puke smell.
There's something and that's why I don't like Yoga.
Hot Yoga rather regular.
Y'All got,
I can endure.
What don't you like it?
Because High Yogurt,
no fart the inside of you by like,
like Yo man,
moms,
her farting,
you know,
straight up.
You got to hide your,
you ever did hot yoga,
you ever had a hot chick convince you to do that shit was like my wife's side so
she could talk me in the most dumb shit.
Right.
So,
oh yeah,
we're going to fucking hot yoga.
Yeah.
Hi Mobs,
tits answers.
Yo this shit.
You got to block for me to say and then it's like Ooh,
pitch to too far.
Yeah.
Like I know my wife are,
that's not my wife Fart.
And then you say fuck it.
You start farting.
Oh No,
no.
That shit is,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I don't,
I don't fuck with hot yoga.
I would rather just do regular yoga and then just saw none of that shit out.
Like you.
Um,
I like hot yoga.
You don't fart and tell the truth.
Okay.
But first thing in the morning,
respect.
No one farts stove.
Oh,
people far for sure.
Staple Fart if you go to the early classes.
Okay.
All right.
The pros.
Yeah.
There's a couple of different places that I go to,
but I like going to the early class.
All right.
Do you get of the same day you hot yoga?
Sometimes.
Most of the time,
no.
Most of the time no double doors.
I have,
if I have an injury,
if I have something that's fucking with me,
but uh,
if I do that,
I almost consider it like a sauna because you get so God damn hot.
Like the room might only be 104 degrees,
but when you're working out hard doing yoga,
your body is poor and sweat.
You must be heated up as warm as you get in a sauna.
It feels the same way.
To me it feels like almost like I'm trying to work out in the sauna.
Gotcha.
This doing some study now at Harvard about it,
about a heat shock proteins and and hot yoga and you know how much inflammation
it reduces and how beneficial is to you.
I forget what scientists were involved in it,
but a bunch of people were talking about it the other day.
I know it definitely gets gas at your ass.
It definitely does.
Well,
if you have something that you shouldn't beat,
and like you eat a hot dog with sauerkraut and a coke,
and then two hours later try to go to yoga class,
you're a criminal,
you're a terrible person,
fucking Mofo.
And there's nowhere for that far to go either.
It's stuck in the hot dog,
and that's the thing is stays there.
That,
but if you get the real earthy chicks,
they burn sage,
and then that starts to suffocate you and you got to leave the real earthy
chicks.
Yeah.